يوم واحد من جوله اعاده الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه هبطت الليره هبوطا حادا
لتسجل ادنى مستوى لها ما يقارب 21 مقابل
الدولار الامريكي اسباب هذا الانخفاض
الحاد تعود الى التدخل المباشر لرجب طيب
اردوغان في السياسات النقديه طبعا
بالاضافه الى هروب رؤوس الاموال
والمديونيه الخارجيه ساهمت عوامل اخرى مثل
ازمه كورونا تداعيات هذه الازمه الصحيه
وايضا الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
بالمقابل المعارض كمال كليتش دار اوغلو
والمرشح الرئاسي يقول بانه في حال وصوله
الى سده الرئاسه سيفصل ويعطي الاستقلاليه
للبنك المركزي ولكن يبقى السؤال ما مصير
الليره التركيه بعد انتهاء هذه الانتخابات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات